okay so a 39 year old japanese man got
arrested recently for scamming 35 women
i didn't know this was an arrestable
offense but what he did was
he began to date 35 women and he would
tell them that his birthday
is on different day so he is constantly
receiving gifts throughout the year
so he would date a girl that he met
through work
and he works at a i believe a marketing
firm or something
uh he met a customer started dating and
he would tell her my birthday's in april
and then he'd meet another woman and say
my birthday's in july
so he's constantly receiving gifts let
this man live no it says
the women give him around 100 000 in
gifts or 766 dollars
but imagine 766 dollars every
like what that's a yen no 100 000 like
every week
from a woman no totally says in turn
these women gave them around a hundred
thousand yen
a total of seven or six those little
gifts i wonder if that goes far in japan
or if that's
the equivalent of like just twenty
dollars i can't or you can get arrested
for that
i guess so i didn't even know about that
being stupid yeah
i didn't know that was like a arrestable
offense but people are saying that this
is a scam and so he was arrested i mean
there's
bigger schools japan's also very strict
with stuff like that so good for them
could be i mean i say let the homie live
man i mean ain't nothing wrong with that
ain't no
players gonna play man don't hate the
player hate the [ __ ] gifts
yeah shitty gifts
so what they're mad they gave him what
they weren't spending that much money
but also though those women take no
responsibility being stupid enough
yeah they just feel betrayed what else
you got jen
uh just showed you this earlier did you
know much about this american idol
that's my favorite really he was really
good he was a country singer and he was
on there because he was like
i'm doing this for my kid man because he
just had a baby yeah he's i'm just for
my kid man and
where i come from you know no one's made
it and then he didn't
make hollywood so i was like oh that's
all right man
and then i see this he
was arrested booked for burglary and
second degree
felony dude because he wanted to see his
kid that's what he's saying
oh and he gave him this kid from him
yeah yeah she
so when he enters the house that's
considered also hit her in the face yeah
with the palm strike oh boss rooting
style yeah
not that boss hit women i'm saying it's
the technique that he won a world
championship with
like he would he yeah he would hit with
his palm so he didn't want to break his
hands because he did
uh bare knuckle so hit with the palm wow
she can't break your palm it was pretty
badass
oh this kid is not bad enough no no that
is boss yeah his career is over
before it even started really oh he was
all right he was just super raw like he
can't compete with the big dogs
also no american idol last night because
the oscars thanks for that
yeah so like what uh
he's going through trial right now no
they said his bond is 15 000.
he was released on the same day so chin
see if you think he can sing click on it
page is cecil rey who's talking about
his kid right she's doing great she just
turned
two months four days ago
he has a nice he's raw nice sound yeah
so i think they're thinking is oh if we
get some
actual coaches behind him he might be
something and he said hold on let me hit
my girl in the face real quick
[Music]
not great hunting no but he has a nice
sound he's got yeah he's got a raw
country guy they have on you know you
can only have one country guy the
country
oh the beast the one that you really
really like yeah he's a mullet he has a
weird he's almost too cool for the show
he feels like he doesn't give a [ __ ] he
wears a hat because he was a [ __ ] guy
wait is that the one that got out of the
because of the contract
no that's a different guy that guy's
white oh that guy is more old
yeah there's like a real country and
he's only 16 and writes his own music
he's a beast oh [ __ ]
he's too good for that show yeah oh
all right okay so a ring camera
captured a ups driver helping a child
stuck
underneath the package what the hell so
uh i guess he delivered this 95 pound
package and this little boy tried to
drag it in himself and help his mom
his mom was actually upstairs with his
two-year-old uh little sister she was
changing diapers
and suddenly the package just falls on
top of him he can't lift it up and he
gets stuck
the ups driver hears him screaming for
help runs back
and helps the little boy what the [ __ ]
she get delivered that's 97 pounds
oh he's all right no not yet not yet
yeah i think he was just scared the mom
came downstairs with the uh
baby girl and was very confused about
what happened because she saw that her
like son was shaking up then there's
this ups man with a package
that's a weird introduction yeah but
everything for the work yeah he did yeah
he got that quick
the little dude was all right this is a
weird one
uh last year at the very beginning of
the pandemic there was a guy
named josh uh what's his last name swain
he went online and he put out a notice
saying i
am john swain i'm gonna go out of my way
to tweet
and dm every single man with the name
john swain in the united states to see
who is
the josh swain and he eventually
created like this facebook group where
they all met in one area in nebraska
random green field it's josh swain
versus josh swain in a rock paper
scissors contest to see who is the
official winner gets the name
yeah and on top of that he said that
anybody named josh come to this field
and we're gonna duke it out
uh we're gonna fight with pool noodles
bring canned goods so we can donate to
the local food drive we're gonna donate
to
a um hospital and this
this is the outcome so this is the rock
paper scissors
this is the finals the rock paper
scissors to see who
is the official john everyone's name
there is josh
or yes josh not john just just fight for
a different name
[Applause]
[Applause]
okay and then if he keeps going so that
was the official
official person who now has the name
josh swain
and keep going keep going there were a
bunch of other
this one like this one there were a
bunch of josh's that came and
basically fought to see who the best
josh was
they went with pool noodles this reminds
me of like role models
you remember at the end at role models
when they're doing larp yeah live action
role play
yes and if you keep scrolling down you
name a kid josh if you want to they
named the official winner
oh my god i've never seen role models
they are they named the official winner
of the
josh battle as this little boy josh is
five years old
he got a burger king but yeah this whole
random thing happened during the
pandemic because people were lonely and
bored
they donated a bunch of money to a local
hospital in omaha
they donated to the food drive oh so it
was a charity thing
they they created it into a charity
thing oh gosh i thought they were just
doing it i was like damn
this is something my ex would have made
me go to
that's probably why he's your ex cat
hey they look like wait so he that that
little kid is the
he's the official winner of the name
ben the knee at josh they said that's
cool what else got you
this woman here was charged with a
fennel felony embezzlement for keeping a
vhs tape
sabrina the whatever teenager bringing
in the teenage wish and the cat
yeah yeah don't can't you just pay the
fine no she didn't even know oh wow so
it was like
so she would actually lose jobs and not
know why right because that [ __ ]
honor of
her background if you background check
let's show felony embezzlement which
sounds crazy
wait what did she do
she was married to someone or she was
dating someone and i guess they rented
this
show for the kids and then the guy
didn't return it so
it just kept going on and on and on if
you don't pay for it remember we were
just talking about this not too long ago
but eventually you just own it and they
charge you i don't know yeah [ __ ]
certain amount
so i didn't know that get charged on
your like uh
your record though well after a certain
like uh monetary amount if you don't pay
you have a warrant for your arrest
that's all he was saying would jackass
at blockbuster yeah i don't think this
is blockbuster though i think this is
a random like mom-and-pop store yeah
yeah that's who would report it because
blockbuster that's a company i don't
care about
but i heard that uh mom pop store
actually isn't even in business anymore
so if they went to court
it's like the town that she rented it
from versus her
not like the company they took it all
took it off yeah they took it off so
she's good yeah she's good now okay i
mean
imagine all the jobs about she's
wondering like why am i not getting
hired yeah yeah
i'm overly qualified yeah yeah i get it
okay i saw this with elon musk saying
people will die
traveling to mars like a red egg dog the
amount that he says it though is kind of
it's trippy i'll let you hear from he's
hosting saturday night live
yeah that's the other one to be able to
move off earth while we have the
opportunity everything we know
is right here and just because it's like
it's um it's not it's
he put on some pounds he's i think he's
got to be on t right
uh uh maybe because his head looks
bigger
his jaw he looks so fat
no rich you got to be to do an interview
with no shoes going through the
antarctic it's a long journey
you might not you know come back alive
uh this hair plug game is but it's a
glorious adventure
and it'll used to be bald you know
if an arduous and dangerous journey
is a mueller you may not come back alive
he says it multiple times glorious
adventure
sounds appealing to the place and you
still have
thousands of volunteers if not millions
of volunteers and then this part
honestly a bunch of people probably will
die at the beginning
over there a bunch of people probably
die in the beginning so why would you go
in the beginning
too it's like that yeah that's that's
what happens man that's why we're here
yeah you know how many people die trying
to discover america and other [ __ ]
countries
yeah yeah that's gonna be hilarious
miley cyrus that's a trip too huh
oh [ __ ] coming up yeah
and i saw this it's a sailfish we talked
about this before
almost killing this guy that scared me
that's adorable
god look how close i got that that would
hurt
that thank god air
because it's still dangerous inside the
boat when it's moving around but that's
so close
are they shanking them after yeah
they're beating the ship you got it
i forgot someone actually wrote in
saying that
they have like an electronic thing
that's that shocks them and kills them
jesus christ yeah what a taser something
something like that but for fish
like in his brain i don't know what it
is
and it just automatically kills him you
should kill him right away before i
believe we had to bonk him but when
they're this big it's got to be tough to
kill him
oh yeah um
wait this is yours okay from before oh
yeah this was from last week
so uh lizzo made a tick tock video
saying that she was really drunk one day
and slid
into captain america chris evans dms and
she didn't think she was gonna get a
response back
and he ended up responding because i
guess she went online and apologized for
sliding in while she was drunk he said
that he's done
more questionable things on this
platform than that which was his
dick pic getting leaked and shortly
after
absolutely our boy chet hank said
a piece of lizzo he is all for
black queens and a white boy summer
where's uh his where's uh chet hanks hey
this is his story
so he took us uh he reposted her
captain america i'm here baby white boy
summer
black queen summer [ __ ] yeah gosh he's
great
he's hilarious all right
um i saw this we were tagging this a lot
this guy is incredible he is look how
big he is and how
athletic he is and technical
you don't get it no damn oh [ __ ]
he's pretty damn good yeah
and i think that's pretty much it other
than okay there's some vin diesel stuff
yeah
what happened what happened i just saw
this i don't know what he's doing
exactly
does anyone plan this what he's doing he
said the last chapter yeah for fast nine
and that's his it's gotta be his music
in the background why does he have a
mask on
his house yeah yeah it's actually not
too bad some of the stuff
that's not him singing no he comes in
that's his house does he live in the
safari this doesn't make any sense he's
just he just made this video
he doesn't explain it no he has a mask
on at his own house
and that's the director of fast nine and
that's him being done
i think so
[Music]
that's him oh that's gotta be him has he
directed all of them that guy
no no no no the more recent ones he has
[Music]
i mean it just doesn't make any sense so
you're just walking around hell yeah
and then uh the last thing what is his
life
just wanted to quickly wish everyone a
happy birthday
um and we're celebrating of course by
uh another fast 10 story meeting
i don't get incredible director justin
taking in this beautiful earth right as
we're about to
commence working and that was it i want
to see him i want to see his i'm
responsible
video
i don't think he counts because he's
cuban yeah i was oh he's cuban oh yeah
where
he's one of the tables get there if they
rode the bikes there that's what i'm
worried about right now
everything is worried about this whole
thing i mean the whole thing is the [ __ ]
joe
it's just funny he says i trust he's not
black he's probably i think so yeah
there's a little bit of
yeah that's what i thought he was i
thought he like was mixed
and his name is actually cuban oh it's
mark vincent's real name he says i truly
love our planet
and he was a break do you see when he
was a breakdancer he
used to be a breakdown skinny too he was
all skinny he had hair
yep him and leonardo dicaprio both broke
uh he used to be pretty cancerous
yeah he did uh uh leonardo dicaprio
you know that little uh dance break yeah
you killed it yeah he used to be
i think a popper wow
with the left leg kick left left leg
and remember to teach you how to do yeah
you ever see that video ryan gosling
getting down on the disney
uh the disney kids thing oh yeah him and
justin timberlake
and [ __ ] back in the day he was like
getting it he's like doing something
he's pumping it right there
god damn
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
right he's killing it oh with the emcee
oh that hand stop look at that
guy he's feeling it he feeling it though
he can like traditionally dance
he's trained dancer like you saw him in
that uh one of my favorite movies that
the movie won all the awards
he liked that movie that's good i love
that movie yeah i love that movie that
one over uh
uh that won a ton of awards no moonlight
won over
la la land and they had that weird that
weird thing yeah battle but la la land
they
won a ton of awards this is why eva
mendes yeah yeah right
yeah they still going strong they are
they got kids huh yeah yeah
i love doing uh the other guys oh she's
so good yeah
so funny i love doing this oh she's a
gators [ __ ] yeah
get it don't play no [ __ ] that fact
right away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what just run a bunch of other comics
i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got gotta
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son